so once I got my weekend working with
their Center so we're both working on
Center and then when I come in
we gotta move away from this what are
you picturing come here like Oh
attending everything or you're like
super strong I guess but that's not the
technique so his centers is have I'm
gonna bring it in and turn it around
[Music]
this other one is like your kids playing
with dads do you understand yeah watch
it you want to kill this sensor you
don't feel it
that's it get into shikaku and turn this
enter and then you'll walk out
[Music]
on the last couple reps he kind of
turned on I'm just working on turning
here you can see it we cease when I
throw him he with his okay if I'm gonna
wait he doesn't turn and then disengage
like this you see that you can feel your
Center relaxes in order for you to do
that okay because if I just keep the
motion going
now you language your pelvis in the
disengaged position and your back was
not protected
okay
you he enters the following station then
then I'd like a new technique so I work
on his center will turn his center and
look it's not this he's found the
straight up and then I take so this
movie senators should already be turning
rolled it done okay try it again it's
just on the different side of my body
Walter and I don't eat you if you're
generous connected you're in cooking
wall where her head stays in a
particular place
[Music]
so I said to her bus right here you see
that so and here here will stay here
and my body is in that one did you get
it
do yourself ok so if you try to push
back on me it's not me leaning it's me
ground me
do you think see how he moves okay if my
head if my head is in my Center and I'm
browsing through where you're touching
me my head will not do this do you
understand so now you're going to call a
team you know yet which is just Kokomo
other side your body your head should
not move your head going to come in here
[Music]
so if you just engage your Saturn from
your head that's where you go okay but
it's the same technique his Center is in
there and I turned the center and he's
already following it's just two
techniques two techniques one is Kazushi
and legs knees Polly did I step in a
wool turn the center boom and then I'm
[Music]
oh okay okay so it's the same thing I'm
gonna sock you see I'm right here so if
I change my stance I put it here with
this arm will be here in front of me
but it's looking wrong I'm over here I
did not the game but this part here is
exactly say I'm going to turn this
Center woo
so just like this is wrong Kokila that's
wrong
this is wrong and even are you guys
standing straight up they're gonna go
like one time you're not not the balance
is broken here boom right there you're
not throwing a backward you're not going
one way
[Music]
you know 3:19 code you roll forward Bob
Byrd you know max out that's high I'm
turning it
[Music]
turn you guys think of it just I'm
changing my idol
I've been here wool and then I'm going
to techniques but the second one is not
the rope that yours is reposition okay
try